bon écoutez les Français les mois je
pense qu'il faut aussi ne pas avoir
l'oreille sélective et aujourd'hui les
Français ils demandent effectivement la
suppression de ces régimes spéciaux ils
demandent de et oui ils demandent la
suppression de ces régimes spéciaux moi
je les ai entendus les Français
et il demande aussi pourquoi est-ce
qu'un plombier pourquoi est-ce qu'un
boulanger pourquoi est-ce qu'un coiffeur
aurait moins de droit qu'un qu'un
chauffeur de la RATP à Paris et donc
effectivement il faut harmoniser il faut
faire en sorte que pour pour lutter
contre les les iniquités nous puissions
avoir la suppression de ces régimes
spéciaux et puis je voudrais rassurer
quand même madame de La Gontrie c'est la
crise de la Gontrie non nous n'avons pas
la tête qui tourne en tout cas pas dans
la majorité présidentielle et nous
sommes plutôt cohérents c'est le seul
gouvernement qui aura fait et qui aura
eu le courage de supprimer les régimes
spéciaux mais c'est le seul gouvernement
aussi qui supprimera les régimes
spéciaux avec la clause du grand-père et
nous ne voterons pas pardonnez-moi
président Retailleau mais nous ne
voterons pas le l'amendement Retailleau
qui voudrait accélérer ce départ et donc
nous nous souhaitons effectivement
maintenir la clause du grand-père mais
tout en supprimant les régimes spéciaux
donc nous voterons contre cet amendement
ces amendements de suppression
madame jasmin
[Musique]